[Music]
no mana deacons
managers strategist she says as a man do
not extend your hand first why
under roles in the workplace so I feel
that women are capable talked about the
sexual harassment you talked about and
if we don't put limits on our
interactions and we don't curtail our
interactions you can enter a very
dangerous territory you don't see the
UFC having a man and a woman in the ring
right assalamualaikum guys welcome to
another episode of the Dean show I'm
with brother Imran who is the founder of
the wall away podcast he's also a
strategist and consultant former
director of baina Institute we're gonna
get some strategies we're gonna get some
principles for business we're gonna pick
his brain and hopefully everyone can
benefit who's watching when we come back
here on Adi show don't go anywhere
how are you good how are you I'm doing
well so tell us a little bit about the
wall away sure because you're nanhua low
wala non low Alva non well out yes so so
the wall away the wall away is a podcast
I started earlier on in this year to
focus on the things that I'm passionate
about some of it is about leadership
some of it is about health a lot of it
is about mentorship and how we can apply
certain principles into any aspect of
life for example sometimes we talk about
sports in the wall away but we talk
about sports from a leadership position
so when we examine things that happen in
sports we examine why why do certain
athletes act in certain ways what's the
psychology behind it we've had
psychologists in the show on the wall
away to talk about certain decisions in
sports but we talk about a variety of
things but I'm very passionate about
leadership education and health those
are primarily what I discuss on the wall
away now you were with the Institute the
baina in statistic that was run by
Norman Ollie correct and you were the
director of this Institute I had a few
different positions there my first
position was basically as Noman of the
Khans
manager strategist after that I became
the operand the operation side of the
nonprofit side of banja and I was also
the director of the dream program mm-hmm
so well I wore many hats so you got a
lot of experience from being there I'm
doing I'm doing I had you know I had
experience before I got there and I
definitely gained a lot of experience
while being there so it's always a
pleasure and a benefit to be able to
work with students people from different
parts of the country people from
different parts of the world to work
with talented staff so it's always a
great experience to gain wisdom to gain
insight and to also impart whatever
wisdom means that you may have so you've
had the experience before you came there
you got some more experience while you
were there so now what is what what can
you give to us now when you come into a
lot of these organizations that some of
the things that you see that are being
run right done right some things that
are done wrong and how people can
improve so they can go ahead and better
ship their leadership abilities and go
ahead and and and do a better job
irregardless of whether one is in the
nonprofit or for-profit side everything
always starts with leadership right so
when when when everything when
everything is when everything is
effective from the from the top right
everything that trickles down is
effective so leadership principal
leadership methodology is very important
the leader has to be one who has a
vision a mission the leader has to be
one who is encouraging conflict dialogue
just imagine right
imagine if right now what we're doing on
the Dean show is we're dialoguing is
that correct yes
if we don't dialogue if you don't bring
guests on to your show and dialogue with
them we miss out on a lot of knowledge
we miss out on a lot of opportunity so
as a leader whether you're in a
nonprofit or for-profit side you got to
encourage a dialogue you got to
encourage debate conflict not personal
attacks but the ability to question why
certain decisions are made and to
question why certain strategies are
implemented so one thing that I would
say is when you're when you're in a
leadership position or whether you're
running an organization try to hire the
right leader try to have someone who has
experience in leadership try to make
sure that the leader is someone who is
honest someone who is modeling the way
this is a very important principle in
leadership what do we mean by modeling
the way now if I say I am
about integrity integrity and honesty
right but you see that I'm not a person
of integrity I cheat I lie I steal how
would that impact your understanding of
me would you respect me
no you wouldn't respect me so as a
leader you got to model the way you got
to be an effective leader by being what
you claim you are so whatever values I
have as a leader whatever values that I
express in the organization I have to
embody and live those values once you
once you model the way one thing that I
say is very important to do is to
encourage like I mentioned before
encourage debate so you have to have you
have to be comfortable with conflict
right conflict is good if you watch a
movie if you read a book what's at the
center of most movies and books conflict
right can you think about a movie or a
book or anything that you've seen that
doesn't have conflict it has some type
of a dilemma it has some type of issue
that's trying to be resolved okay so
when we have this conflict we have to be
able to be open and transparent if we're
not open and transparent guess what
people are not gonna commit to whatever
decisions that are made because if I
call you guys into a meeting right now
and I say okay let's talk but I'm really
the one doing the talking and I don't
let you express what you want to express
and you just nod nod your head yes and
agree with me the reality is once once
we try to implement whatever this
decision is you're not gonna buy you
just quite a few things but those are
three very important things what do you
do when you open up that door of
dialogue and conflict and now people
where you keep it balanced where people
are expressing their views and then now
the when everybody is having their
thoughts expressed but now when you
don't go with their thoughts are
expressed and then egos get in the way
and hurt and have you had these
situations happen absolutely and then
someone doesn't agree with what this
person is saying and then it becomes an
argument how do you balance that out
this is why as a leader you have to
embody your values so number one what
are your values do you stand for justice
news stand for integrity if people
respect you as a leader and they see
that you have integrity you have values
and that you're principled they will
accept what decisions you make part of
accepting your decisions is that that's
what you have to implement you say you
go into a meeting you say look we're
gonna have a discussion but by the end
of the discussion we're going to go with
one
you know agreed principle and I need to
have consensus on that you allow for a
debate to happen people get passionate
people express what they what they
believe in
once you reel it all in and you go with
say I go with employee A's opinion and
not employee B you it's a very simple
thing employee B this is what the
majority accepted this is what I
accepted as a leader let's go forward
with it and let's see how it goes what's
very important because to counter what
you said if this thing doesn't go right
who has to take ownership of the of the
of the loss you do the the leader does
and if you take ownership of it guess
what that shows to the team shows many
things it shows number one it's okay to
be wrong it's okay to take ownership of
doing something wrong and now this is
why leadership and team-building and
running an organization it's a process
it's not a one finite event right small
wins not big ones so if you have the
right people on the bus if you have the
right people on the team I don't really
find that the question that you posed to
be a problem people buy-in people you
know agree with what has been agreed
upon you know this is why when you hire
people or when you hire different
positions you have to be able to hire
the right people see people people get
caught up in the losses people never
talk about the successes right or it
could be both ways but here's what I
mean I go in as a consultant and I see
that the leader of an organization is
complaining about toxic environment a
toxic work environment people think that
this happened in one day no it happened
from the time before you interviewed
that employee even the principles you
use to interview employees have to be
adequate and proper you know I have to
make sure that the person is the right
fit for the organization so there's many
ways to examine that but in summary
again I don't think it to be that big of
a problem when you employ the right
tools have conversation have dialogue
let things fall in place and again this
is where we have to be able to
differentiate conflict is not bad
conflict is not bad ideological conflict
is not bad right what is bad
is personal attacks if I say Eddie you
know I think we could do this better or
I think we should use this type of
microphone or this type of camera or
maybe we should do this with the lights
you should accept that if I say Eddie if
I personally attack you right if I
attack your demeanor if I attack your
looks if I attack your intelligence how
would that make you feel how would that
make you feel you wouldn't feel right so
again conflict is good as long as it's
not personal the texts you're not
insulting someone is you're trying to
get your opinion across
right correct and also part of the
training is to do what we're talking
about with your team so I would sit with
my team and I would take them through
this argument right or I would take them
through these principles by saying look
there's gonna be times during the course
of the year or the course of this you
know consulting session where I may not
agree with what you're saying and you
may not agree with what I'm saying that
is fine we can disagree we can even
argue respectfully we are not gonna
personally attack each other and when
you sit down with people and you tell
them that
disagreeing and conflict is okay
sometimes they question it right you
even have to take them in baby steps to
this training and allow them to
understand that these things are okay
when you see when you listen to some of
the entrepreneurs are out there and you
see some of the character traits that
they talk about a leader having and then
you see you compare that to Islam so
let's say for example they talk about
being punctual being honest they talk
about pretty much Shura sure right but
then when you see do you see those
things in the Dean that the Dean also
teaches those same exact thing just like
waz like they read a book on on Islam
I've had those moments happen throughout
my Master's I got my masters in
education and leadership I've had those
aha moments happen when I've read a lot
of the books by the so-called gurus in
leadership but yeah there's a lot of
connections so one of the first things
is respecting people you know a lot of
the the work that comes about comes
about leadership entrepreneurship
team-building has to do with respecting
others letting people talk do we not
have examples from this of this from the
Sunnah do we not have examples of people
coming to meet the Prophet
and him giving them a voice him letting
them talk him letting them finish
speaking even though he would probably
make a certain decision he would give
him the opportunity to share their
vision share their thoughts share their
opinions right and then when that
happens and even if another decision is
made people feel invested they feel look
I was heard my opinion was heard it was
it was discussed there's many other
there's you know what stopped at that
one right yeah yeah I mean this is this
is really important because if you don't
let you want to be heard and let's say
you let someone like the Provost awesome
he will let someone talk and then after
they're done it's how you finish and
then not interrupt them and have you had
these situations in a meeting at home
this is just any time in life you're
listening to someone and then as soon as
you want to get things going and express
yourself they start cutting you off and
then it keeps going and then I'll cut
you off again but hold on you just said
quiet for like five minutes 10 maybe 20
and then now it's your turn but they
don't let you talk imagine we're at the
workplace okay imagine we work together
and I'm the leader you you are on the
team every time you want to talk to me
about something an idea that you have a
problem that you're facing at work while
you're talking every time I cut you off
and I stop you it happens the first the
second the third and the fourth time the
fifth time when you're thinking about
coming to speak to me what are you gonna
what's gonna be going through your head
what are you thinking you can't get
anywhere with this person I'm not even
go into this vision right so again when
you allow people to finish speaking they
feel vested they feel okay at least this
person is gonna hear me out so this is
one great example you have to let people
speak you have to respect their opinions
another great example and this is very
pertinent for anybody in HR anybody in a
leadership position pay people on time
pay people on time what's the
translation of the hadith you know it
yeah before the person is what drives
before the sweat dries off you pay them
how does this not relate to the common
work era if I am giving you 40 hours 50
hours of my life a week right and you're
not paying me on time it's gonna be a
problem
but we have this solution in the
pay people on time why do we pay people
on time when they're giving you their
expertise they're giving you their
knowledge they're giving you their time
respected pay them you know their people
use money it's none of the business of a
leader or HR to think about what these
people need the money for right so
sometimes you'll have experiences where
they say oh the payment came a day or
two late
no that is none of your business meaning
if it's only a day late they should be
fine with it no we don't know what type
of bills people have we don't know what
type of expenses people have on a weekly
daily or monthly basis so pay people on
time you have these situations where I
just heard a story from a brother he was
talking about how now there's obviously
nothing wrong with trying to get a good
deal some people call it wheeling and
dealing
negotiating right to get a fair price
but then once that price is negotiated
and now the brother he's talking about
I'm praying with this brother everything
is good you know and then we get into a
business transaction we make a deal
let's say it was the deal was $400
that's what we agreed upon I started
working and now he's hitting me he's a
brother can you do it for 60 he's
already invested his time is effort he's
they've made the deal the deal is for a
hundred or a thousand or whatever the
course and now while they're doing the
deal he's he's already invested he's got
him he's already sweating brought his
tools and now he's trying to come in and
get a discount what do you call this not
this is unfortunately not uncommon right
yeah but again do we have any safeguards
in their religion to protect us from
this happening we have contracts right
we're encouraged to use contracts again
in that the professional level we find
many organizations especially many
faith-based organizations not using
contracts they don't use contracts they
do not write they do not put pen to
paper and write down what they expect
from the employee nor does the employee
write down what they expect from their
employer and then what happens one month
in you haven't got paid is it in the
contract when you're supposed to get
paid oh there's no contract so there's
nothing to fall back on okay I I was
called in to do XYZ but now they've
added more tasks to my job well what
does it say in the contract I don't have
a contract again Islam has the
for a lot of these problems you go in
when you when you even if I'm not an
employee I'm I'm not a normal employee
right but say we want to go into a
business venture together say we have
intellectual property that we're
discussing is IP right what can we put
in into place to safeguard both of our
investments both of our ideas you can
use NDA's you can use contractor
contracts you can use any type of
template there's many many services
online now very easy to utilize right
which will protect your time your ideas
and your investment but the problem is
we don't like taking the extra step to
use these contracts but we have to even
if it's a at a smaller level absolutely
the guys come in to change your toilet
what's wrong what's wrong with using a
contract that takes five minutes to
write out or this is something just you
can take a pick up a pen and just on
your own just a paragraph a sentence you
don't even have to do it because people
think contra I need an attorney I need
to spend you know money to draw this up
we're not talking about that if you are
going into a bigger venture something
that's more complicated definitely get
an attorney right okay do you have
services like Rocket Lawyer great
service you sign up for it you pay a
very minimal fee a month right and it
according to what state you live in it
gives you a set of laws for that state a
certain level of understanding okay now
I want to go into a contract I want to
get a plumber does it there's a template
for that there's you don't have to even
write a paragraph it says who is the one
receiving the services in Marana know
allah who is the one providing the
services okay for example say it's a TV
audiovisual consulting the Deen show
what's the address of the business this
is the address how do you expect to be
paid right it's as simple as fill in the
blanks very small words very small
phrases and the contract is that a few
minutes so there's no complications
later on you have something to protect
not only you this is what I always tell
people when people call me about going
into they want to use the wall away or
my other business digital learning
partners as for consulting what I say is
let's sign a contract not only to
protect me but to protect you so another
thing that I do is I men
tor Millennials right so part of
mentoring Millennials is that a lot of
times when they feel comfortable with
you which is built through trust when
you when you when you show them that
you're trustworthy and you're honest
they start opening up and they start
sharing ideas what I say is if you guys
ever want to bounce an idea off of me
let's sign some documentation they say
but it's you I said but it's it could be
a million-dollar idea it could be a
million-dollar idea believing yourself
but not only believing yourself protect
yourself what are you supposed to do
trust in the law and tie your camel
right tie your camel take the means that
are going to protect your future this is
not only your future this is the future
of your children this is the future of
your family this could be generational
wealth so what I do is I have the the
mentees create an NDA that I have to
sign to protect their ideas and when you
do that believe me
it goes a long way with the mentees they
take it even more seriously right
because now they're trying they're
interacting with god-willing
people of integrity people who have
their best interest in mind not only my
own best interest and you find that a
lot of the times and in businesses our
deal seems very good something seems too
good to be true but you find that people
are just trying to be essentially be
predators they're trying to find Talent
they're trying to eat up this talent
take concepts and ideas from people to
keep themselves going but you know as
Muslims we have to be above that we have
to be beyond that we know that our risk
our provisions are written we're going
to get every penny that we are supposed
to get right we take the means to
protect ourselves but what's wrong with
wanting for your brother or your sister
what you want for yourself I want to be
a millionaire but how do I become a
millionaire
I want that for other people until I
show that sincerity I should not expect
to get it so you see you've you've
witnessed a lot of that bit you can't
business predators yeah it's a phrase
that I just used right now but
unfortunately in every and every aspect
not just in faith-based organizations
and other organizations the reality is
we know that this exists in the non
faith-based realm we don't want to
believe that this exists in the
faith-based realm but why shouldn't it I
have has every employee been vetted
has every person that you've brought
into the organization been vetted and
I'm not talking about any specific
organization I've dealt with a lot of
different talent a lot of different
people from different parts of the world
different parts of America from
different organizations and you find
that people are very similar you find
some people who are always very sincere
but very sincere people are often
trampled upon walked over and their
ideas are taken from them why because
they don't put the proper corrective
measures in place and then you find
another extreme you find people who look
professional they look great but
sometimes their their knowledge in the
Dean is not where it should be and the
practical parts of the Dean the entire
look the entirety of Islam is practical
right but if you're going to be working
in a professional setting you should
learn the fit of working in a
professional setting you should learn
the parts that are pertinent to being a
leader the parts that are pertinent to
being an employee right there the
religion has parts that discuss that so
unless you learn these things unless you
learn the principles of the religion
it's very easy that either intentionally
or unintentionally you are going to take
someone's rights or you're not going to
be doing justice to your job yes so you
have to learn these things what have you
learned and what advice do you give for
now when you have the male-female gender
roles in the workplace
I mean look do I feel that women are
capable and competent human beings
absolutely we got to dispel this notion
that women cannot do a lot of the work
that men do they've proven that wrong
but we have to also be cognizant that a
lot of the issues that happen at the HR
level in organizations and you can read
a lot of case studies about this have to
do with sexual harassment have to do
with discrimination based on gender how
do we curtail this number one we have to
understand that fundamentally we are
different beans right we're all humans
we're all equal but my chemistry and
your chemistry is different right and
when islam teaches us that being in
seclusion with a with a woman for a man
to be in seclusion with a woman or for a
woman to be in seclusion with a man it's
not only one weights both ways can be
problematic right if we're to be honest
with ourselves and we should be honest
this is one thing that people do not
like being anymore which is honest
is that we have certain desires we have
certain ones and if we don't put limits
on our interactions and we don't curtail
our interactions we can enter a very
dangerous territory so one thing that
Islam does is we have certain dress
requirements for both genders as a male
I'm not allowed to walk around naked I'm
not allowed to walk around exposing
certain parts of my body right for a
woman it's the same thing and rightfully
so we want to be able to concentrate on
what the task at hand is not on looks
right this is why sometimes people are
against meetings by phone or meetings
over the Internet I'm completely for it
because what you're able to focus on is
the voice you're able to focus on what
is being said not what is what you're
gazing upon you have to let's be honest
with ourselves we go on social media we
have we over here locker room
conversations how do men most often talk
about women in a derogatory way
derogatory way talking about them
physically when you remove that side of
it and all you get is the woman's
intellect her voice her opinions what
are you left with her intelligence her
ideas right not to say that women should
be completely removed from the situation
but we have to understand that certain
rules and regulations are put into place
moreover just to kind of curtail the
relationships right we have to
understand that relationships at the
workplace should be professional right
so if I'm interacting with the sister at
work what what are some do's and what
are some don'ts this is somebody come
sister how are you I'm doing great
how's your family mashallah they're
great okay that's good right
by the way were you able to finish the
report that I asked for or by the way
how is the design going for
such-and-such project when you start
getting very casual and very comfortable
this is where you start getting into
that danger zone because you remember
wait for you to go from point A to point
Z say a is the ideal and point Z is
complete disaster it doesn't happen in
one big leap it happens in steps so
those steps they take time so one day
it's one piece of conversation the
second day it's another piece of
conversation the third day it's okay now
whenever we speak we're three or four
feet up
Hart now we're speaking we're two feet
apart two weeks later we're one foot
apart next thing we know it were
shoulder to shoulder it happened step by
step so you kinda you need to realize
what is professional what should be left
in the house what should be for the
workplace I think I brought this example
to you before when I was in high school
in 2004 as a senior I went to a
non-muslim high school and I was the
class president of my high school right
we went to this mandatory leadership
training with high schools across the
state thousands of students not an
Islamic training a very qualified woman
got up and she was giving us some advice
she goes when you introduce yourself as
a man to women this was 2004 not very
far back not in the 70s not in the 80s
not in the 50s she says as a man do not
extend your hand first why she says
maybe the women don't feel comfortable
shaking hands this was not a Muslim
woman she says let the woman extend her
hand first to see if she's comfortable
with it keep a certain distance what
happened to this time this was from whom
a non Muslim woman who was giving
leadership training to high school
students across the state of Illinois
mm-hmm right but again you find a lot of
relation to what she was saying to our
principals right so there's a lot that
I've learned over time there's a lot
that the the theories entail more than
the theories is the life life
experiences right you don't want to get
your heart broken you don't want to
break up your home so when you interact
with the opposite gender at work keep it
professional keep it professional stick
to while you're at work you're at work
for work you're at work to get a certain
task done a certain job done you're
there with a certain mission and vision
in mind think about that only how about
now before you even not when you're
choosing a role let's say you really you
want to get out there and what's your
what should you be your vision your
objective is it just for I'm choosing
this career just for me or we're limited
in a certain area where they need more
people in this particular field so now
we're deficient here and I'm gonna to
help the Ummah to help the community or
I'm just like just filling out resumes
just to be working at McDonald's look so
they're not going to have those same
yeah it's different you're in
the environment is going to set the
stage for probably what comes next
so excellent question of course whenever
you do something you should always think
how can i benefit doma how can i not
only do my right when we say oh man
let's define what we mean by the OMA we
mean human beings right
you mean all people because of as
Muslims we believe what we have is
beneficial to everybody and I know that
you've talked a lot about this in your
show this is what I talk about on the
wall away as well is mental health
physical health so we have a solution
for everybody to answer your question
you have mentorship is very important so
sometimes we are in a position in our
life where we think we know what we want
but we haven't accumulated the right
amount of experiences to know exactly
how to get there or maybe how our life
can change every 5 or 10 years so when
I'm 18 or 19 I think I understand the
world I think I know everything and to
an extent you do but mentorship is
important so what I would say is find a
mentor find someone in the community
that you trust have them mentor you and
how have them help you decide what you
fit into
for example cause another another
important principle in leadership is
competency competency right so as a
leader you have to be honest but number
two you should be competent what do we
mean by that you have to be competent in
your specific role you have to be
competent in navigating the culture at a
workplace if you don't have competency
as a doctor right you're not interested
in learning chemistry and biology and
Anatomy but you say I want to become a
doctor how is that gonna work out right
so with whatever position a person wants
to go in to develop those competencies
so if I want to become a graphic
designer
what are you doing to learn graphic
design does that make sense yeah yeah
we've had a lot of people fighting
against themselves I mean the cultures
change you know people start to define
their way of life according to the norms
of society what have you seen because
we've seen a lot of women even men but
particularly because they call it as a
doggy-dog world it's a rat race so
you've had people now make certain
decisions and they put themselves and
very uncomfortable
predicaments you talked about the sexual
harassment you talked about people now
you know the man will get up go out into
the rat race of life go to provide for
his family now it's become kind of a
competition right some of the roles are
mixed up have you seen this course now
we know that it's beautiful in Islam
because you have the two genders
complementing each other right
biologically they are different right
but they being spiritually create
spiritually that is same in the sight of
God but they have you know you don't see
the UFC having a man and a woman in the
ring right gather together there's a
reason and there's a reason for that but
then we've we've had a lot of sisters
and women in general
now that they've they've they fought
sometimes against themselves and now
they have they have everything they have
because it's it's a man's duty to to
provide for his family he's the
maintainer and the protector when
somebody wins a UFC fight and they grab
the Joe Rogan brings over the mic and
he'll start speaking what's one of the
first things that they do I'm gonna
leave it to you what's one of the first
things that they do they bring away win
what I I just want to fight you Joe
Rogan put some mic in my face what's one
of the first things that they say who
did they think what do they think yeah
yeah yeah pretty think yeah depends who
the person is tell usually the team the
team they say I think you know thank you
to my coach thank you to my trainers
thank you to my team why why because
this is a team effort very often we see
one person going through the journey and
winning but we don't realize that even
these winnings our team efforts same
thing amongst lions you brought up lines
okay one is protecting one is hunting
one of my specialties is team building
this is what I love doing and I own the
podcast what I try to exemplify is using
examples from sports I'm a big fan of
basketball and the San Antonio Spurs the
way the Spurs win is by finding people
who fit specific roles like you said how
do people complement each other a
husband and wife complement each other
right everyone has a designed designated
role when we start trying to do what the
other person is a good at we have
redundancies we have inefficiency we
certain tasks being done in certain
tests not being done it's the same at
the workplace it's the same biologically
right one person usually bears the child
right is that right or is it that the
man is bearing the child as well know
the woman's burned it so the woman is
bearing the child and we find that these
examples translate into many different
spheres and realms so we have to be
honest and I think you put it the best
way and we can leave it there compliment
how do we complement each other right
now we are on a talk show we are talking
to each other we are complimenting each
other you are not talking to yourself I
am not talking to myself this is a
compliment we don't have a problem with
this right there's a mutual benefit
marriage is the same there's a mutual
benefit right Hey look there's a there's
been a lot of things that have happened
throughout history to kind of start
changing these dynamics a lot of authors
and researchers have pointed out that I
believe it was World War one or World
War two when the the the you know in
America when the men went out to Europe
to fight the woman were left alone and
then the women were sent to the
factories to build the war machine to
build bullets ammunition etc so
traditionally women were not working
outside of their homes now the all of a
sudden overnight they were sent into the
workplace they were making their own
money they were providing for themselves
that's not the only issue young boys
were left with these women so
traditionally what would have happened
is the father would have been a part of
rearing his son maybe he took him out to
the farm he took him to the workplace
he took him in the car they went
shopping but now when the father's
overseas in fighting you're left with
the boy being completely reared by the
mother which look I'm not saying that
the mother should never rear the child
you have a mother I have a mother we
know the benefits of our mothers
instilling certain principles and values
within us but we also need a father
right
we need a father and when you take
either/or out of the equation it's
detrimental yeah
it's detrimental another author pointed
out that when you go into the schooling
system preschool kindergarten who are a
lot of the teachers in preschool
kindergarten and land and elementary
school it's women again we're not
knocking this but when there's balance
there's a benefit so we have to bring
balance to these things and we have to
repeat we have to be honest I'm not
saying that everything that I've said
right now is 100% accurate I'm open to
criticism I'm open to dialogue but
that's the difference when we talk about
tolerance versus intolerance part of
being tolerant is being able to have a
conversation but most people don't want
to have conversations especially in 2018
when we talk about gender roles
psychology whatever these things are
people do not want to have a balanced
conversation and especially one side of
the spectrum balance yes we will
conclude with that balance keeping a
balance in Islam is a balanced way of
life and you know what the beautiful
thing is the one who created life the
owner of life he didn't leave us to
figure these things out on our own
he sent the guidance it's there so
whatever field you're going you have the
thick of this vic of that everything is
there according to the verbatim Word of
God the Quran the Sunnah everything is
there have you found that of course
everything is we it's not for us to be
fumbling in the dark but when people
start following their desires they start
ignoring this that's when they start
getting lost and end up making a lot
more mistakes rather than adhering and
looking at okay what does my Deen say is
this acceptable it's not I'll leave it
I'll make an adjustment but that's when
you put the crater first and then things
usually fall in line much better have
you found that look put the tablet down
turn off the computer put the phone away
be introspective just sit down at the
table lie down at your bed take out the
headphones and think think about your
day think about your doings think about
your actions we make humans we make
mistakes but the benefit is when you're
introspective what led you to make that
mistake
what can lead you to avoid making that
mistake and as you mentioned Islam is a
balanced way of life Islam has a
solution for a lot of these problems but
it's gonna start when you're
introspective right now we're too
connected we're always connected to
either Facebook Instagram social media
YouTube our TVs our phones our tablets
this is disconnect for a while find a
time in the day where you can disconnect
and just be introspective think think
meditate you know you've had guests on
previously and you've talked about it
many times eat right eat right right
lower that inflammation in your body
when you eat right and that inflammation
is lowered you can think right yes you
can be right
I think positive be positive fill your
heart feel your brain feel your stomach
with good things and then it's easy but
you have to start with being
introspective you need to ask yourself
some hard questions
beautiful work at people hamdullah get a
hold of you the wall away you can go on
the wall away calm that's the wallet
wala way waa y calm while away also has
a Facebook page you can hit me up on
there and look up in Raanana wallah on
Facebook or Instagram and I'm there
thank you brother yeah good thank you
good having you thank you so much yes oh
yeah there you have it the wall away
with our brother Imran Islam has left us
a complete guide from A to Z on how we
need to live our lives and be
introspective think ponder everything is
there subscribe if you haven't already
get the little know notification tab so
you get our we our shows weekly sent to
you we'll see you next time here on
today's show until then peace be with
you Islamic please subscribe to the D
show follow us on our official Facebook
and Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]
you